out of the covid pandemic and the
dangerous delta variant first found in
india that is now causing trouble in
china health workers and scientists
there have been fighting it
for the past three weeks and they say it
could be a bigger threat than the
initial coronavirus that originated in
china
18 months ago remy innocencia is
tracking the spread
of the delta strain good morning from
here in hong kong the epicenter of
china's latest coveted surge is right
behind me
all of that and that skyline there is in
guangdong province
and doctors on state-run media have been
warning that the delta variant
makes patients sicker faster from swabs
to
jabs china is racing to stay ahead of
the fast spreading delta strain of kovid
some people lining up for miles to get
vaccinated in guangzhou
capital of china's southeast guangdong
province
an estimated 150 000 residents are still
under lockdown with workers in hazmat
suits delivering them food
and disinfecting the streets in three
days health workers tested nearly the
entire population of about 19 million
the epidemic in guangzhou is an
unprecedented opponent
and requires our resolve said the deputy
director of guangdong center for disease
control
the delta variant of kovid first emerged
in india this spring
3500 people are still dying on average
each day the most of any country in the
world
according to the new york times and the
strain is now the most common
in the united kingdom but there is some
good news today chinese health officials
are now saying that the surge is easing
but they're warning
that future flare-ups could follow as
we're here in hong kong no reports of
the delta variant
just yet but that's because no tourists
are allowed only residents
case in point myself last month i had to
do a
three-week mandatory hotel quarantine
at the time it was longest in the world
and some still say
it was the most brutal all right raymie
nocencia reporting from hong kong thank
you